e aí galera cheia para assistir o meu
cana tudo bom com vocês
e aí galera se desdobrado vocês sobre
paulo a demorar um pouquinho mas aí vi
eu tô doente mas mesmo assim eu tô
gravando vídeos panceiro então já clicou
não gostei
tiveram facebook já clicando em curtir o
elenco é hoje em dia muita gente usa o
facebook se a pessoa não tiver facebook
elas até mulher para o facebook a essas
coisas aí tem mesmo é como se fosse uma
doença mas se o cara tiver facebook já é
anormal na nossa sociedade como quase
todo mundo o facebook como quase todo
mundo tem facebook acaba que tem algumas
pessoas que começam a notar algumas
coisas um digamos interessantes à
internet enquanto dp futebol foto de
bosta até porque o imposto é de alívio
então você já está pensando e agora que
estou fazendo esse vídeo para falar com
essas meninas uma foto do suspeito no
facebook e ainda por favor se valorize
não estou falando que eu gosto também
não porque na realidade eu acho uma
bosta
mas eu não ligo não faz uma coisa que
poucas pessoas na internet fácil que é
olhar sentir vergonha alheia e fechar
bem identificar reproduzir para todo
mundo o que eu quero falar aqui dentro
desse monte de gente que possa fotos
dela na internet existe um grupo que é o
que eu acho mais desprezível mais tosco
todavia na vida pelo que chama de falsos
princípios da internet tem um tipo de
cara que ele sai procurando na internet
forte menina com decote grande demais
mostrando a bunda pra ficar comentando
nossa
as meninas de hoje em dia e fica morta
no respeito na internet
nossas meninas de hoje em dia tem que
aprender a se dar valor a quem está a
mentir mão mas e aí você acha que esse
cara se importa nem com essa menina que
estão ligados kiomi lx cru homem nós nós
somos bichos e pinto buscar scrum é o
cara vai lá e mostra que você está muito
vulgar minha por favor se valorize mais
um dador minutos catalá se valoriza vai
se valoriza
valorizou argumenta nossa e um pouco de
russo na foto dos seus peitos é um
pouquinho daqui a pouco né cara não é
aquilo que ele diz não é aquele
recomenda e isso coloca o documento
quando a pessoa compartilha faz com que
a informação ótima então dica para os
homens e de ir para as mulheres como
você vê a foto de menina um peito de
maio do lado de fora bruno e mais rude
mais você olha e expresso deixa a água
pronto sua vida voltou a ser normal e
legal como era antes a 8 mas o pessoal
fica mandando coisa direta suas fotos
direto exclui a pessoa uma dificuldade
que uma pessoa com a nossa me excluiu e
agora como falso pode aparecer vai tomar
no cu os usuários do facebook você pode
ser legal quanto você quiser no facebook
fora dela se pode ser uma bosta época
paulo
é o avião um avião eu falo então é bom e
eu acho que se você tiver oferecido este
foco do meu chapa se você tiver o
facebook você já compartilha isso aqui
espalhe nas redes sociais foi fã 11
faltas fez subir para os programas
sociais estão pedindo também quer
mediante segue no twitter
assim no facebook segue no instagram
comenta que o macho que você mais odeia
nas redes sociais e é isso aí inscrever
se para receber vídeo novo time novo e é
isso aí falou